Chỉ có ăn nghe, nghe, nghe, nghe,
từ chối không có chuyện tạm đi nó nghe không biết cái gần này là cạnh dịch.
Này, cái gì là mọi người thấy có loại gì đó là thành công,
người ỏ hình là trong gia đình này thì có ăn thấy sử dụng.
Mì rất là nhiều những cái thích khác nhau,
được chỉ thuật đến sản tẩm đến,
kiên giang đến, nó phát đến,
có là những thích của sả hội,
ở như là ăn cái lần.
Hồi hai lấy năm, là sao hai lấy mại được quá,
có thể dạy thở luôn.
Đại vì thật sự ra là,
thầy đến,
đá là một cái hành tạng mất,
Mình không biết cách mình hậm ghét như thế này, mình phải học đó như thế này
Dạ, mình không có gì hết, mình sẽ là mình có thể mình bị động vũ
Họ chỉ là ăn ghê nền hình, mình hẹn còn từ chối không, mình phải chuyện tận đi nó là không biết cái ngàn này là cạnh dịch
Họ đã có ăn ngừng nhớ nữa
E ra là bọn lắm chuyện tìm mới ra mắt cái dung cao của người dùng quá nhiều, sau mấy là cái kiếp kính hình
Mình không đủ tìm, mùa xa và ở đây là ăn là phải gọi là
Bây giờ, hết tất cả cái cái cái người được gì mình có lập chỉ là đi
Mặc nể ý rô ta, mắn chịu thì mình luôn
Mà lúc đấy, chỉ có có cái người được gì mà là mẹ mình không phải dếp kính hình ở đây
Mà lúc ấy tự nhiên là đối dịch của chịu là người làm game có chịu phát hay chứ
Thậm chĩ là có cho đẹp của nó mà mình không phải dụng cái gì mà đối dịch
Tống cửa bởi vì là người không có người được
Chân ơi là không biết có phát như thế nào mà không biết phát thì không được làm
Mình không đồng là to ăn chịu con xam mình tổng tại được rồi
Sống qua con chẳng này, mình sống qua tháng này mình có gắng là mình bựa của nó được tế
Mình dạy quyết hết, tất cả từ có hành này có hành hẹn
Mình bà đếp, hành hẹn hẹn lại bại thì mọi thứ nó ở nịch là một phíc
Lúc đa nhé, trời ăn mấy người xúc mấy nhau
Mà hãi có hãi là chúng ta là ai
Và chúng ta...
Mũi